all right i don't want to spend a ton of
time on this many of you emailed me
about it this is really funny
newsmax host greg kelly is calling out
rudy giuliani and saying dude you're
claiming you got attacked
it seems like you're exaggerating so if
you haven't followed this story let me
back it up for you rudy giuliani was at
i guess it was like a shoprite
and
someone came up to rudy and kind of
patted him on the back and i guess said
something negative to him okay they
patted him on the back and rudy just
turned around and looked at them
before the video was out rudy was
claiming that he was hit it felt like a
boulder that it knocked him multiple
steps forward he thought it was i mean
that it was just like this crazy vicious
physical attack
then the video came out and it becomes
very clear that it was not some guy
patted rudy on the back and said
something negative okay
rudy has doubled down and he keeps
talking about this assault and this is
so funny even cuckoo for coco puffs
right-wing newsmax and its host greg
kelly says i gotta be honest rudy it
really doesn't look that bad so if
you're watching you'll actually see the
video of the i think they play the video
of the supposed assault check this out i
didn't know he was this good i really
didn't and his
uh his grasp of the by the way rudy's
audio plagued by background noise
particularly in the issue of pride in
the
it is remarkable
and the main thing that he has is
passion tremendous passion hey mr mayor
is somebody mowing the lawn right
outside your window i can barely hear
you
we're at a big rally we're at a big
rally in staten island
right around the corner from where i was
attacked yesterday
we have that actually you were at a i
guess a delicate testament of some kind
i'm going to show the people what
happened and you tell me because let me
see the video if you don't mind uh
this person with the hand on your back
i gotta be honest it doesn't look that
bad but i i understand that looks can be
deceiving
you know that that was
that was the woman who was rubbing my
back not the guy who hit me but you're
watching
so the woman that woman uh
gave a statement to the police that the
guy hit me so hard that she herself
almost fell yeah it's very clear that
didn't happen from the video the
reverberation of it she's a city the
entire building echoed from when rudy
was patted on the back it reverberated
they were worried it was going to break
glass
there's a second grade detective
that that's that's the lady who uh
helped me oh all right good that makes
sense uh yeah um guys when greg kelly
from newsmax is saying you know it
really doesn't seem that bad
you might have gone a little bit too far
saying that it reverberated throughout
reverberated throughout the building can
you imagine so okay so that's the rudy
thing i don't really want to talk about
it too much more but uh and of course if
if some if someone doesn't want to be
touched they shouldn't be touched that's
absolutely the case okay so i'm not
defending but it was like a boulder it
knocked me forward multiple steps the
guy patted rudy and rudy turned to his
left
that's all that happened okay so greg
kelly is not buying it
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping